NOTICE HIM.
THIS IS THE WORLD THEY CREATED
AND THEY ARE HAPPY WITH IT.
AMERICAN POLITICS IS
INCREASINGLY HAUNTED BY A
STRANGE NEW SPECTER.
THE MOCK BILLIONAIRE.
THEY ARE LIKE SOCIALISTS.
HOW DOES THAT WORK.
A VENTURE CAPITALIST DECLARED
THAT ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ IS
AT THE HEART OF AMERICAN
POLITICS AND HE IS FOR THAT.
>> IT'S EASY TO CALL WHAT SHE IS
DOING IS FAR LEFTY.
NOTHING COULD BE FURTHER FROM
THE TRUTH.
WHEN YOU ADVOCATE FOR ECONOMIC
POLICIES THAT BENEFIT THE BROAD
MAJORITY OF CITIZEN THAT'S
CENTERISM.
WHAT HOWARD SCHULTZ REPRESENTS
IS JUST TRICKLE DOWN ECONOMICS
WITHOUT THE OVERT RACISM.
HE IS NOT THE CENTRIST.
AOC IS.
>> Tucker: THERE IS TOM STIRE
USING HIS WEALTH TO ORGANIZE AND
LEAD IMPEACHMENT RALLIES.
>> I WILL BE DEDICATED 100% OF
MY TIME, EFFORT AND RESOURCES TO
ONE CAUSE.
WORKING FOR MR. TRUMP'S
IMPEACHMENT AND REMOVAL FROM
OFFICE.
>> START IMPEACHMENT NOW.
>> NOW THE IMPEACHMENT QUESTION
HAS REACHED AN INFLECTION POINT.
>> 100%!
FOR IMPEACHMENT.
>> I INSIST THAT THIS PRESIDENT
BE IMPEACHED.
>> Tucker: CALL ME SKEPTICAL.
YOU THINK THERE IS A SCAM AFOOT.
MARK STEIN HAS IDEAS AND JOINS
US.
WHAT IS GOING ON HERE?
>> WELL, I THINK THE WOKE
BILLIONAIRE IS A PHENOMENON OF
OUR TIME.
THE WAY YOU GET RICH NOW IS NOT
THE WAY YOU GOT RICH IN THE 19th
CENTURY OF THE ROBBERS.
THESE WOKE BILLIONAIRES ARE LIKE
ROCK STARS.
BONO GOES ON ABOUT DEBT
FORGIVENESS FOR AFRICA.
WHEN HE WANTED TO SAVE MONEY, HE
MOVED HIS MUSIC PUBLISHING FIRM
TO AMSTERDAM FOR THE LOWER
TAXES.
HE DIDN'T MOVE IT TO AFRICA.
THAT'S THE WAY THESE GUYS ARE.
THEY UNDERSTAND THAT THEY ARE IN
A WORLD IN WHICH STRIKING
ATTITUDES, THAT PRESERVE THEIR
OWN POWER BASE IS MORE IMPORTANT
THAN ANYTHING ELSE.
>> Tucker: EXACTLY!
THEY ARE SMART ENOUGH.
THEY ARE SMART.
THAT'S HOW THEY GOT RICH, TO
UNDERSTAND THERE IS A LOT OF
RULING POLITICS BENEATH THE
SURFACE.
DO YOU THINK THIS IS A DEFENSIVE
MOVE?
>> YES, I THINK IT IS.
WE HAVE DECLINING SOCIAL MOBILTY
IN THE U.S. WHICH IS A TRAGEDY.
>> Tucker: I AGREE.
>> WE HAVE ACROSS THE PLANET.
A HUGE RISE IN THE GROWTH OF
BILLIONAIRES CONTROLLING A SMALL
GROUP OF ABOUT 2,000
BILLIONAIRES CONTROLLING THE
WORLD'S WEALTH.
IT'S EASY TO STRIKE ATTITUDES AT
HOME TAKING ADVANTAGE OF TAX
LOOPHOLES ABROAD.
GOOGLE DOING THE OLD DOUBLE
IRISH.
TAKING MONEY FROM ONE IRISH
COMPANY TO ANOTHER AND THEN INTO
A BRITISH TAX HAVEN LIKE
BERMUDA.
THE WHOLE POINT IS TO CREATE THE
ELITE AT THE TOP AND A VAST MASS
UNDERNEATH.
THE ESCALATOR TO GET FROM THE
BOTTOM TO THE TOP IS RUNNING
EVER SLOWER AND WITH FEWER
PEOPLE ABLE TO GET ON IT.
>> Tucker: DON'T YOU THINK THERE
SHOULD BE SOME STANDARD?
YOU ARE A BILLIONAIRE GOING ON
MSNBC AND CALL FOR REVOLUTION,
SHOULDN'T WE GET TO SEE YOUR TAX
RETURNS AND ASSESS THE TAX
HAVENS YOU ARE USING TO PREVENT
PAYING YOUR FAIR SHARE?
ISN'T THAT THE MINIMUM
REQUIREMENT?
>> ON THE LEFT THERE IS A HUGE
ACCEPTANCE NOW THAT THE RULES
THEY WANT TO APPLY TO OTHERS
DON'T APPLY TO THEM AM IF YOU
MADE YOUR MONEY IN COAL OR
CONSTRUCTION AND YOU WANT TO
KEEP YOUR MONEY IN BERMUDA, YOU
ARE A BAD PERSON.
YOU DON'T EVEN HAVE TO BE A
BUSINESSMAN.
IF YOU ARE THE SOUTHERN POVERTY
LAW CENTER AND YOU HAVE THAT
RIDICULOUS NAME AND YET YOU HAVE
BILLIONS SALTED IN THE THIRD
BRITISH COLONY TAX HAVENS,
THAT'S OKAY.
THE LEFT HAS A HIGH DEGREE OF
TOLERANCE.
THEY THINK IT'S DIFFERENT WHEN
THEY DO IT.
THAT'S THEIR VIEW OF IT.
EVERYONE KNOWS YOU CAN SALT YOUR
MONEY AWAY WITH TAX LOOP HOLES
AND STILL GET INVITED TO THE